Turkish Airlines is already in a good  position in Europe's airline market  passenger numbers have been on the rise  along with revenue and profits it's  already a strong competitor for a large  European airline like Lufthansa even  without its planned advance in the  low-cost sector ryanair is still far  ahead in the number of passengers  transported with 86 million per year  followed by easyjet but Turkish Airlines  now has nearly as many passengers as  Germany's Lufthansa and it has already  overtaken Air France Turkey's flagship  carrier only collects a third of  Lufthansa total revenue but it has been  much more profitable while both  companies cooperate on long-range  flights Turkish Airlines plans to now  offer budget flights in Germany would  make the brand's direct competitors on  Lufthansa home turf